hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
kevin
samuels youtube clip labeled kevin meets
karen the rugged
arguing woman rugged arguing women and
men are equal
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers each and every one of you
help me reach that goal
while you're at it ring the notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily
videos okay
and yeah you know i do think that
um women sometimes and it's interesting
because i've been having this
conversation with a lot of my
girlfriends that are both married and
single at the same time
and they you know they they get angry
when things don't happen
their way and they do blame men
sometimes but at the you know
in the same breath they want to vain
independence and say that they don't
need men
but i think something that's interesting
with a topic that you had the other
night
was stating that women don't need men um
excuse me that women need men and that
men don't need women at all and men
would be able to survive without women
and i think that that's um i think
that's really destructive
towards this kind of bond that you're
trying to build
in women okay before before you say what
you think it is let me ask you a
question
of course is it accurate uh is what
accurate specifically
men who built the infrastructure
if thanos snapped the weight of the
women
men in the main could live to the end of
their natural existence
by simply maintaining the infrastructure
in which we built
correct i think women could also
maintain okay let me
see that's that's the difference between
this let me finish the follow-up
question
could women maintain the infrastructure
they did not build and they're not
trained to run
yes how okay how could women
effectively do that before nature
set in meaning yes you possess the
intellectual capability to read a manual
you possess all of that but still
infrastructure breaks down have you ever
had a manual labor job or a job where
you had to work with machinery
so i so i will say and i had this
discussion with my boyfriend today
i do all my own manual labor at my house
i changed your own manual labor at your
house man but i'm asking you
have you ever had to work with heavy
machinery
um to a lesser degree but if i if i
needed to
such as give me an example um
i worked i worked a job back home uh
in a bakery where i was dealing with
heavy machine literal heaven
heavy machinery what kind of machinery
man um
i mean anything that had to do with a
like industrial baking yeah okay so
no offense but in the kitchen a part of
me
no offense but it's it's in the kitchen
industrial baking
correct yeah okay but what i'm talking
about man is i'm talking about talking
about construction no i'm talking about
power plants power grids i'm talking
i agree i agree with kevin on this i
think that
i don't know a single woman that's
interested in that stuff
like at all and i sure as hell would not
want to do
any of that stuff about refineries oil
wills oil
and i genuinely genuinely don't think i
have it in me to learn
like i don't think i could figure it out
derricks i'm talking about heavy
machinery backhoes
of course things that hold on listen i'm
talking about
the things that negate physical
advantage that men have
right and they're you cannot tell me you
can train a population of women
to get them up to speed to do the job at
the level men are doing it before
women start to die off if you understand
how this country
is run how the power grid is laid out if
you understand how the logistics work
when corona came around one of the
biggest concerns were
that the medication flow was going to
stop because we have a one
drop logistics problem one drop
logistics chain
we don't have much for disaster recovery
why do you think you didn't see toilet
paper
uh and water because
all the logistics broke down people went
bought all of this stuff there was no
more stuff
i get that women have the mental ability
to do it but
how long do you survive without clean
water so
but so um so let can we take a step back
in your argument because the
truth is that physically women don't
have the capability to maintain
and sustain the development that's been
built by men correct yes my am i
understanding that correctly yes you
don't okay
so that that that's where i disagree
with you um
and i disagree with it because i will
say um there's a caveat to this i'm the
youngest of five kids um
my i have uh there's two sisters two
brothers
where are you going to disagree on the
fact about the physical strategy
it is very possible so my disagreement
is that it is very possible for women
to sustain physically an environment
that
men have built without men
no no no ma'am you said you disagreed
with the notion of the strength
difference between men and women
yes listen listen listen no no no no no
you can't overtalk me i don't i don't do
that here's the thing
there's not a girl alive that's gonna be
stronger than
the strongest men
like shaq's gonna body half of these
females
i mean there's some like i'm stronger
than a lot of guys but
if you put me in like a men's college
basketball league i'll get my ass
handed to me even though i was a college
basketball player
okay the average hand strength of a man
to a woman is like a 17 or 70. i forget
them
it's magnitudes larger for a man versus
a woman
in the fire department to be able to be
a fireman
you have to be able to do a 200 pound
dead man's carry
did you watch the beginning of this show
i did i i
write and women fail the test the
physical readiness test
no you can't overtalk me women failed
the physical readiness test
65 percent of the time that you know
what the exercise they failed
you want to know what exercise they
failed hanging from a pole hanging from
a chin up bar
pulling your knees to your chin that's
what the women failed
it wasn't lifting heavy weights it was
moving their own french toast
body weight yeah so telling me just
because you may be a rugged woman
that women like you are the norm
it's a fantasy well so number one i i
i take a slight offense to you calling
me rugged what would you want me to call
you man
you you came in talking about your
background and you worked with
industrial machinery what would you want
me to call you
well number one well without without due
respect that was that was one instance
when i was 16 you asked me for an
example so what would you like me to
call you
you can call me by my name no no
the modifier you are making yourself
seem oh my gosh
she's irritating me she's irritating me
so much
i don't know why like lady let it go
you knew what you were calling into
because though you are different than
most women
are you this okay let's let's back up
yeah we get it
and here's the thing if you don't like
if you watch my show ma'am you should
know how i speak
so this is no slow flake zone as far as
i'm concerned
you can't handle it i'll bid you a good
night there's no snowflake here well
then don't
then what's the insult in calling you
rugged
i think rugged comes with connotations
that aren't that aren't what is the
insult in calling you
rugged rugged comes with connotations
what would you like me to call you when
you're trying to make yourself
seem as though i can do this heavy
machinery i did an industrial banking
i'm one
two or five kids and i was born this way
when most women don't
talk about these things as part of being
their feminine asset
that's considered to be far more
masculine right so but
so your your argument is flawed and this
is you know right my argument's flawed
women it's
okay here's what we're going to
ultimately get to i'm not going to i'm
not going to get into a circular
argument with you man
you can believe what you want to i
really don't care
but the bottom line is you can believe
what you oh my god this lady is so
annoying
ah she's irritating want to but you
cannot show me that if women can do
these jobs
and run the infrastructure why are you
not doing them because they pay better
there and it's easier for women we can
allow men to do it
you don't have to because you're not
that you don't have to
okay well okay so in other words you
benefit off of men doing them
are you honestly are you honestly trying
to tell me that you think yes
are you no i said not going to talk me i
meant that [ __ ]
maybe you overtalk your boyfriend that
doesn't work here
are we clear i don't know how these
grown-ass women don't know how to have a
conversation
not your head and say we clear good
i'll be nice to you if you're nice to me
man but i'm not going to allow you to
overtalk me like that
if you're honestly telling me that women
can get
up to speed and run the infrastructure
to the same level of efficiency that men
can i think you are sadly mistaken but
you are free to be sadly mistaken
may i speak sure so that
i that is not the argument that i'm
making initially you said that women are
incapable of surviving without
men men are capable of surviving that is
not what i said
i did not say incapable i said the
majority of women were not lifted in
no no let me clear you up because i know
what i say because i'm responsible for
what comes out of my mouth
i said women are incapable of living to
the end of their natural existence in
mass
meaning that yes by the time women
actually got up to speed
and learn see here's the thing the
presumption is that the
requisite information that you and other
women need to learn
is digital and that the systems are
still running
but see when the power grid fails all
the information and the manuals
are where they're warehoused in
libraries
and in other places and you would have
to actually physically go read this
stuff
and the time in which it takes you to
actually download and read the knowledge
there are women who are on dialysis
there are women who are on oxygen
they're women who need all kinds of
things women are dying
see how her lips are like pressed like
that
you could tell that she is either
agitated or she did not think through
this argument
dying because you're not the because the
infrastructure is breaking down
while you're getting up to speed there
is attrition
men don't require that because they're
already doing it it's simply knowledge
transfer from one man to another
there's no needing to get up to speed
it's hey man do this this this this
there is no transfer because there are
no women already doing that
can we agree on that part yes and can
can we add another another piece to this
then because you raised an excellent
point to it to
to another piece that women outlive men
in in retirement homes you see more
women
you outlive men because of modern
advances
women didn't typically outlive men
because you would die most of the time
where
childbirth childbirth yeah exactly so
even your even your lengthy existence is
due to men
okay so so then does it isn't that the
circular argument that
no it's not it means it means it means
that the reason you women can
feel like you can do what we do is
because we've civilized the world in
general to where you have forgotten
how hard it actually is to live
ma'am i've said this before and i'll say
it again
don't believe me go after this show is
over
i didn't see this listen okay okay but
listen to what i'm about to say
go after the show is over and go to
amazon prime
go look for a series called the island
by bear
gryllis i know who you're talking about
all right in season two
if you watch it you saw men and women
the producers came out said they
manipulated the environment because
women were dropping like flies
women women through women for the
audience
these people start off on islands they
have a few matches
knife some a little little bit of string
some fish hooks some things like that
and two large canisters
to actually purify water two for
everybody
what did the women do women actually
found a pig not a pig
um when they finally decided when they
finally
they found the pig they found the pig
but they named the pig
they named the pig and didn't want to
kill the pig but when they finally
decided that they needed to kill the pig
and eat something they finally decided
they killed him and guess what where did
the women
after they gorge themselves where they
what they decided to do with the meat
they decided to put the meat into one of
the water canisters
to store it to keep it from bugs and
pests and everything else
and guess what happened bacteria
everything set in
they wouldn't open the water canister
and it was putrid what did these women
do
what did these women do they they took
the putrid canister
and put it in the river and left they
cut their water supply by
half and damn near died of dehydration
damn damn were idiots
they had to go back four days later
after the rescue team came in and said
bam
you can't survive you can't make enough
fresh water on this island there's not
enough you can't capture enough
you need to go take that canister clean
it out
and use it to boil and purify water if
they hadn't been told that knowledge
they'd all be dead that is irrefutable
so i have enough respect for you to say
this don't you think though that that is
fictionalized by
reality tv and oh my god entertainment i
think what
i think what's fictionalized what i
think is fictionalized when i
that's a thing like it doesn't matter
how many facts are in her face she has
no facts that she's brought to the table
like i don't
i don't really care about this argument
at all like a hypothetical situation
that
isn't gonna happen but she
she does not have
like anything that she's bringing i
think it's fictionalized as you women
actually thinking
that there's not much difference between
us because you saw those women
you know ma'am you asked me you saw
those women you saw those women at the
end of six weeks
at the end of six weeks men have built a
functional shelter they had killed large
prey
they had fished they had actually
repaired the net to capture lots of fish
men were living well matter of fact the
only guys that had been taking off the
island were due to actual falls and
injuries
in week five women were still trying to
lead
by french toast committee
ma'am i get that you may be a different
caliber and cut a woman
but you are not the majority
so i'm i'm a girl that's more of a
tomboy
and i'm like not even gonna dispute this
i don't i don't think women could run
the infrastructure
is it not fair then to to say and and
i'm gonna take that as a compliment but
is it is that not fair to say then
that there's an there's a you know a
co-dependency and a healthy codependency
between men and women that we both
require each other for a healthy
existence
no no i'll tell you why it's not i'll
tell you why it's not i will tell you
why it's not let me give you an example
of why it's not let me give you an
example
let's go back a thousand years okay
actually let's go back even further
let's go back and yeah let's go back to
the time of alexander
let's go back to the time of warring
states how come
yeah how come men could well how come
men could live
in armies of all men and be gone from
their city-state province
and live with all men
that shows we don't need you the only
thing we need you for is reproduction
we want you for sex but see even then
a lot of times those guys had pages or
squires
those young boys were sexual companions
of these men as well
the one why when they had followers camp
what was in followers camp the the
brothel
because that's what the art that's what
the soldiers who were had
r and r were able to go spend their
money in the brothels got their sex
because back then the men who were
married
had to be able to provide for a woman
most men lived and died in the military
how many men lived and died
in the military where were the
equivalent women doing this marching
across the world discovering the world
you can't ma'am you wouldn't you don't
have the strength to do it
so we're no we're no longer we're no
longer in alexander the great times
right there's a lot of um modernization
that has
removed a lot of the physical
requirements for men for even men to do
a lot of physical jobs
so how does that take place then in
modern times it how is that because of
me
because men are because because this is
why you see so many because you still
have the military he shows like the
walking dead and stuff coming up
right he calls men still because like it
or not
men even though we're in modern times we
are still
the human animal we still have our
hunter
our hunter instincts we still know what
needs to be done
the only reason women can make the
argument you're making is because
it is modern times ma'am
what is more vulnerable than a pregnant
female
hey you know what there's there's a lot
of women in my life who
my sister just gave birth there's a lot
i that is a
an excellent point to make i think a
woman with a child cannot
hunt for a woman with a child cannot
hunt
she can't do anything exactly so you
require the men
men don't require that men have to be
able to sustain themselves so you
you're breaking your own argument just
in a state of nature
a mother cannot listen a mother
a mother cannot produce milk keep milk
flowing
hunt and take down enough prey
to keep lactating and protect her child
at the same time
she's going to have to leave their child
somewhere
that crying child is going to be left
somewhere
to nature and predators
so isn't there an argument to be made
then for the tribes and the amazonian
and in
in in certain parts of amazonia you mean
fiction
no no no kevin that's actually that's
actually correct
and then in insurance okay i'll give you
wonder woman and demascara okay ma'am
fine i'll give you all the amazonian
yeah because it's a facetious argument
man because when i hear women talk about
you know what about when
they had matriarchies and they had
queens the people who still ran the
environments who were the soldiers
in these matriarchal armies were still
the men the men were still the farmers
the men were still the hunters in the
army
excuse me so but but but what what i was
saying before
and and oh my god this lady's so
irritating
oh my god she's irritating the point and
coming back to what i was saying is that
because things have changed now and men
are not required physically to do a lot
of the things that as you're saying
lady i thought the whole argument
was if we got rid of like got rid of men
what would happen
the infrastructure would collapse and
women probably couldn't do it
most of the women would die off that
makes sense i don't know what we're
arguing about
how is there not been a co-dependency on
men and women we don't because men
okay ma'am the society that you live in
you're saying that like women
are there to give birth and reproduce
the society that you live in the men who
are
not required to do something are still
being sustained by the men who are doing
it
listen listen let me explain it to you
let me explain no no i don't don't
oh you're over talking me ma'am
please don't make me go there because i
know you can hear me
the men who are working the power plants
the men who are working in power grids
the men who work in the refineries and
all these other things
okay i figured out why she irritates me
she irritates me because she's like
passive aggressive
and so like at least with when the like
like other girls will come on the show
they're just aggressive
and while it's like rude
it's not like annoying they're doing
their job then the men are over here
doing what they do she kind of look like
me
oh my god they do that has the society
running
so these men don't have to do it because
these men are
these men know that they were going to
have to train these men to replace them
we know how to run a world we built
there are not enough women over here
doing these jobs
to sustain the population of women over
here there are enough men over here
doing these jobs
today to sustain the population of men
today because it's happening
okay this all makes sense to me that
makes sense
that is the fundamental math you cannot
get around
there are not enough women today doing
the jobs to sustain a population of
women who are not
you require you need us to live is there
then not an argument to be made that if
there are these men
can you at least acknowledge knowledge
that before you make another argument
yeah i i'm gonna what i want to add can
you acknowledge it before you ask
before you acknowledge can you
acknowledge before you add
because i don't like women moving the
goal posts no no i hear what i hear what
you're saying of course but you have not
acknowledged it
how would you what i would you agree or
disagree
okay would you agree that there are men
running the infrastructure environment
and men over here not running but we
have enough men running the
infrastructure environment
to where these men don't have to would
you agree
uh that's the current setup
saying that there are men that are
dependent on the other men that are
running the infrastructure
the current setup yes yeah yeah all
right would you also agree that in the
current setup
there are not enough women running the
same set infrastructure
to provide for the same population of
women using infrastructure
yeah of course i've never i'm not
disagreeing all right ma'am
well if that's the case what you're
saying is the women who
are in the minority over here can keep
it running at a level to where
what she's basically saying is you can't
i don't know if you understand the math
of this but i'm not trying to be funny
but
you're basically trying to say a
minority of women that already exist
can keep an infrastructure running that
it requires the majority of men to do
you're basically saying
let's say let's just give a number to it
let's say for the infrastructures women
are running infrastructure at a 20
rate i'll give you 20 that means 80
still by men
that makes a total of 100 running it for
51 percent of females and 49
of males so 80 of the infrastructure is
being run for 49
in males 20 of women are running
infrastructure
for 51 percent of males if we look at it
as just male to female
but if you take that away you're getting
100 production from the from the grid
20 of women cannot produce for 51
of women when it takes 80 percent of men
to produce a 49
of men it's mathematically impossible
yeah absolutely
look what you're saying isn't false what
i what i what i want to ask you
um because there's i think there's a
missing piece to this
in terms of um what i'm understanding in
terms of what you're saying
is that if there are a a certain um
percentage of men who are dependent on
the
the larger group of men who have
sustained this infrastructure why do we
need them then
you know so what's their value in this
uh well okay they answer your question
hold on hold on hold on
if there's a certain percentage of men
over here surviving
and these guys are running the
infrastructure why do we need these men
could you say are you asking the
question why are the men who are not
running the infrastructure needed
correct uh well the men termed them as
necessary because those are our
replacements
those are the people who come in to do
your job see there's always going to be
somebody at the front of the peloton and
at the back
see men understand that we need each
other and we're willing to do these jobs
just like on the island there were guys
who hunted there were guys who built
fix fix nets but we never tried to act
as though one were greater than the
other
we understand we need one another women
try to act like everybody's equal
and that you can all do it on your own
the reality is this man women in this
country in this world you're running on
override
men have provided a world of plenty
enough to where you can even make this
argument
and for the audience i need you to
remember something a key point
this woman and i'm going to bring out
your color right now this
white woman first came in saying that
you were having this argument with who
i'm sorry it was an argument with a i
didn't hear the word you said you
whoever you were having this argument
with who earlier today oh i was having
no it wasn't an argument we were having
a discussion about discussion with whom
my boyfriend yeah
exactly yeah you got a man yeah
thank you i do
that's all i'm trying to make you got a
man so understand something you can make
these women's arguments
you can make these equality arguments
but at the end of the day you still got
a penis in the house
and and hopefully you go home and use it
because it sounds like
putting up with you as nice as you may
be ma'am you must be a piece of work
get out of here bye she even had to
laugh at that [ __ ] herself bye veronica
oh my gosh that lady was the most
adorable i think that's literally the
most annoying lady i've ever seen
in kevin samuel's show oh my goodness um
final thoughts i don't even think that's
that controversial
like no i don't think the majority of
women can run the entire infrastructure
but let me know in the comments if you
agree
or you disagree with me do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell and i'll talk to you guys next time